get out and get active because today is  national walking day to celebrate we  track down the 10 best walking trails to  visit here in the valley that's  according to reviews on yelp you can  find them listed at eight newsnow dot  com one way to always go walking if you  have a pet  you're all  right  you can take your pet ted's entire  family is coming in oh and you could  take them on a hike ted the larendo  family hike i thought about but i don't  think the weather's gonna be good when  they come here would they be a little  jacket or something a lot of wind  really really i had to warn them okay  yes because they're they're ready to  jump in the pool and shorts i said yeah  hold on hold on hold on  hold up maybe in a few weeks